foreign
is with us in San Francisco hey Anna how
are you
I'm good thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
okay so I recently went on a game show
and I had the opportunity to play for my
dream car
I got so close but I lost
and it's just killing me I'm so sad
about losing and not getting this car so
my husband and I talked it over and
um we want to know a can we maybe afford
to buy this car
and B if we can is it a wise thing for
us to do because sometimes dream cars
are just dream cars right
I I am sorry I'm trying to recover from
all of this in the moment
um what is the car and how much does it
cost you know the answer to all of this
by the way I'm BMW X3 and it's 50 000 on
the money how much money do you make
oh well to get combined because I don't
work right now is about 175 a year okay
and the car is 50 000.
yes what is it brand new
it's a BMW X3 oh you said that okay all
right so do you currently have debt
no debt no debt do you currently have
savings
we have just over 100 Grand in savings
yeah and what do you drive right now
a minivan what does he drive
we just have the minivan that's it you
have one car to your name
um we have one card to our name we do
have another car that we are kind of
borrowing on and off it's like a little
tiny um like a what do you call it like
a Honda CRV we're borrowing it on and
off as we occasionally need a second car
from my mother-in-law I'm assuming
you're not to a million dollar net worth
yet or am I wrong
um actually we are we are because of our
house okay we have some 401k
is now here's here's our rule of thumb
we would normally say that if you're a
millionaire
you could purchase a brand new vehicle
but we also say that we don't want more
than you know you don't want more than
50 of your annual income tied up in
vehicles so that's why I was asking what
else you have you checked both boxes oh
and you got to pay cash you checked all
three boxes
when did you uh when was the game show
episode when were you on it
about a month ago
and you've got the 50
paid cash for it right
we do but then it just dropped our
savings to about 50. I but which is
still 50 Grand is still three to six
months expenses for you right
yeah
definitely so just walk me through I'll
be honest with you starting out this
call I was like this call is crazy but
you do check all the boxes but you still
sound like uh I don't know like at first
you sounded really excited about it and
now it's almost like as I walked you
through it you you're feeling more
sobered about it and now you're feeling
like you don't want to so explain that
to me
well so before I went on the show we had
sat in this car we had driven this car
and we had said to ourselves hey if
someone gave us this car for free
absolutely we'll take it wise we weren't
sure if it was wise and so we walked
away from the lot several times not
buying this car but then I go on this
show and it's right there and I play all
these rounds and I'm like 50 50 away
from it and I lose it and I'm like oh
maybe I do really want this card well
the game show the game show aside I'm
sorry you lost but what game show was it
can you just say it
are you not allowed to this is Right
Price is Right I love it
um game show aside you'll I feel like
because it was offered to you for free
you were like yes I won and now that
it's not free anymore you're realizing
man fifty thousand dollars is a lot of
money here's the thing you can afford it
you get sounds like you guys have
sacrificed to win you've been driving an
old minivan
I if you can afford it and it here's the
thing if you can't afford that one what
if you got a year or two used
would that scratch the itch and and
still make you feel like you're being
responsible because here's the thing you
would be being responsible even if you
bought it outright
but right now it sounds like you're
dealing an emotion and it doesn't feel
responsible would it feel responsible if
you bought it two years used
I think that would feel better I think
what
it feels kind of scary to do that yeah
you guys have done a great job with
money to get where you are
and so you have good instincts
and this is bothering you I used to have
a friend on investments he would say
when in doubt don't
and you have so much doubt around this I
don't think it's going to bring you as
much thrill as it is going to bring you
loss of Peace just you you're again
you're you've checked every box you're
not violating a single thing that we
teach by buying the car but you've got
to sleep you've got you this is Bob now
you got to pay cash for it okay but uh
but if you're not going to if it's I'm
I'm a little bit afraid just listening
to you that it's gonna take more from
you than it adds to you you know what
I'm saying I just wanted to buy for free
yeah I'm not the host I can't help you
with that I'm on the Dave Ramsey show or
the Ramsey Show not the Price Is Right
otherwise I would just give you the car
but um yeah I get that though I would go
get I I think I'm with Jade because of
the hesitation not because of anything
else because it's bothering you I think
I would go buy a 30 000 version of this
X3 which is a great car by the way
they're very cool
um
drive that for a while if you guys
continue making 175 000 a year and you
continue saving money and you continue
you'll be able to drive anything you
want to drive
the truck I drove over here today I
would never have dreamed I would buy a
truck like that you know like 10 years
ago and now it's like oh yeah it's okay
you know but I I never drink even though
I had the money 10 years ago I would
never but emotionally you were ready to
buy it emotionally I'm in a different
place I had you know there was no angst
I went yeah sure Sharon you okay with
this yeah let's do it okay kind of a
five minute conversation I'm like oh I
love it order the dadgum thing you know
so but but the first time I moved up I
Remember The Angst yeah what she's
feeling I remember this sense of um am I
being dumb I don't want to be dumb
that's a good that's a good thing to
have those breaks on you way to go I
think that's part of
honestly I think that's part of this
process when you buckle down and you're
saying no to yourself a lot even if
you're saying not now when you finally
get to the time that it's now it feels
weird
I think a lot of people struggle with
that actually spending their money yeah
oh they do it's uh it's hard and
you know if if you call me up and you
made
eight hundred thousand dollars a year
five hundred thousand dollars a union a
5 million dollar net worth I would tell
you to just go do it now I will tell you
go do it but this is a it's 50 of your
liquid savings that does that kind of
gives you a little bit a moment there
and you're catching the throat and I
think it depends also how your net worth
is distributed if all of it's in the
house most of it is she said yeah so
yeah that that's a good point too you
know so I
you're okay to do it if you want to do
it but you don't feel good about it
that's what we're observing yeah this is
the Ramsay show